caitlin: Hello!
caitlin: The task for today's self-guided sorry. The title for today's self-guided
caitlin: is SGT.
caitlin: Tracking your expenses with money. Manager
caitlin: 5. And the slug is
caitlin: UOC.
caitlin: I dash
caitlin: RC.
caitlin: LL. Dash 1, 2.
caitlin: Hello! My name is Caitlin. I'm blind, and the assistive technology that I'll be using to day is talkback on my android phone. and the app that I'll be working with is money manager, and
caitlin: I will be doing doing a lot to day.
caitlin: But basically tracking expenses and
caitlin: yeah, overall tracking expenses
caitlin: to give you a brief overview. How I use my screen, reader, I primarily sorry primarily navigate via swiping
caitlin: right to move down through the screen left, to move up to the screen
caitlin: down and up to navigate by specific elements.
caitlin: and
caitlin: to interact with with elements, links, buttons, etc.
caitlin: I double tap occasionally. The double tap does not respond to double tap again. That's not a problem with the app. That's a talkback quark.
caitlin: Trying to think there's anything else I missed. I don't think so. If I do anything else with it, I'll definitely let you know.
caitlin: Okay, so our first step is to create some expense categories
caitlin: and add an income. I'll be holding my phone up at an odd ankle.
caitlin: my manager.
caitlin: because I can't share my internal audio through zoom on android. So let's swipe to the right here.
caitlin: Oh, it's in landscape.
caitlin: No next heading, no video setting. Tuck my under there. Okay, now, you should board one. Consequences. Open navigation to one. Okay, accessibility is set to be 5%.
caitlin: One sixes open navigation door, but open navigation, draw button
caitlin: months, expenses, button more options, button. I'm just trying to get the layout of land here. I'm just looking to the right category. Name your expenses this month.
caitlin: next time, bye?
caitlin: At expense. Okay, perfect. Add expense is the one I'm looking for
caitlin: built up. Have any transaction. Okay, Mike.
caitlin: product category, almost. I go. Now, drop down, list, double tap.
caitlin: and it's not registered. Little tab.
caitlin: I don't forget box. Get it back down, drop down list.
caitlin: It's interesting that there's a drop down box here as well as enter info, and it's an edit field. I wonder if once I start adding categories.
caitlin: then maybe that'll be something I can select there. I'm not sure. Characters enter 0 10 entering box.
caitlin: Okay, it's a little confusing here when I'm supposed to enter. But I'm going to enter something hopefully that'll create our category. We will. We will find out double time
caitlin: to let you know how I type on the keyboard. I slide my finger across the screen and lift when I find the letter that I want.
caitlin: Okay, tucked in food. Now I'm going to tap with a single finger in the middle top of the screen and go ahead. Box. I drink a window at new transaction.
caitlin: Okay, I think it said, food? Oh, sounds good.
caitlin: That's face I love fit on the app. That's face. Oh, yeah.
caitlin: that takes
caitlin: that's face. Okay?
caitlin: Well, we'll try it again. Okay. F,
caitlin: okay. Touching the little screen. Perfect. Says food switch to the right.
caitlin: Clear text, button, clear text button switch to the right characters. Enter 4 of 10, swift to the right.
caitlin: Enter info edit box. Not sure what that means. And that's me.
caitlin: Transaction date. Oh, you can actually add transactions from here. That's interesting.
caitlin: 2024, hmm. 2024.
caitlin: Okay, the app said to add categories and income. So I'm trying to just add categories. I'm trying to go in the order which the directions say. So let's see if we can touch to the top of the screen. Okay? So back to the left.
caitlin: Okay, add you concession. Oh, this is a new transaction. Oh, part of category.
caitlin: You touch it, mic, down, drop down list. Have your transaction.
caitlin: Let's swipe back the screen.
caitlin: I did not work. So I back a screen. There we go.
caitlin: I try and forget a box. I'm going to turn.
caitlin: Okay. It had to hide the keyboard first.
caitlin: And now you just want.
caitlin: Come on. Okay.
caitlin: But navigation format.
caitlin: Okay? Hmm. Russia's fun cory name. I'm not sure if category or add categories will be under a menu or more options. Let's try more options.
caitlin: Koala.
caitlin: Add income. Okay? Well, that's a good place to know where that is settings settings. Okay, when you're back.
caitlin: Censor this one toilet census
caitlin: total expenses add expense. Oh, just say add expense. I'm so sorry I didn't. I thought it. Just add category. Name. Hmm.
caitlin: How do you add categories? Maybe under the menu is open. I have a decade navigation drawer. It'd be more helpful if this open navigation drawer said.
caitlin: like menu button, because open navigation drawer is. I don't actually know what that means. So double tap
caitlin: expenses, budget categories, double tap
auditory.
caitlin: Oh, oh, I think I see. Okay.
caitlin: Category name budget unlabeled. Oh, so this is an unlabel button.
caitlin: and because it's in the same place as the add expenses was I'm gonna assume it says add.
caitlin: but I'm not sure.
caitlin: So let's double tap
caitlin: budget category. Info.
caitlin: yay, category name. Okay. I apologize for my confusion. That was that's kind of on me because I didn't realize it, said add expense. I thought it said.
caitlin: alright. Now I'm gonna type food. Microsoft. Oh.
caitlin: perfect! Again! Just step on the keyboard. I found the letter that I wanted by sliding my finger or touching it in various places, found the letter I wanted, and I lift my finger off the screen to enter that letter.
caitlin: Alright. Double tap
caitlin: 6.
caitlin: I don't have some keyboard bye.
caitlin: We don't pay 0
caitlin: 0 0
caitlin: 500 bucks, but perfect. Thank you.
caitlin: Keep our tone budget, category info food box guide, our name teamwork.
caitlin: Okay? But it kind of went down. Edbox. Cut my name. Pause, please.
caitlin: Apologies for the pause. Just had to change something in my android settings.
caitlin: Let's continue characters. Your text button. Okay? So 500 has been set like the maximum amount of money you've been spending this category.
caitlin: which was the maximum amount of money you could spend this category.
caitlin: add income button. Now, I don't know if I'm supposed to add income from here or add more categories. Info. Hmm.
because that definitely says, add income, not at at category.
caitlin: But this is budget category. I kinda wonder if this button is mislabeled. So let's double tap on, add income and see what happens? This says, add income for sure.
caitlin: I wonder if it's supposed to say, add category. Let's table tap money manager. open navigation for one. Okay. Money manager, open navigation door
caitlin: category name, budget list.
caitlin: Food. Okay? Perfect. Alright 100. It's good. I got $500 and less.
caitlin:  yeah. So one thing I want to mention here. This is $500. If there's anything on the screen letting a cited person know that that's the maximum amount you can spend in that category. It'd be helpful to know that as a screener user, if that information does not display it, then looks good. So let's add another category
caitlin: double tap.
caitlin: So you may have heard it says detected icon add but it before it says.
caitlin: but actually it doesn't say on label button anymore. That's interesting. It's
caitlin: but it says, detected. And that means talkback is trying its best to detect what that buttons label is. But that's definitely not reliable. Unfortunately, because oftentimes it just says, you know, detected Icon, and it doesn't. You know, it isn't able to actually read what that button is. But it would be really helpful to have an official label for that button, so let's double tap.
caitlin: but a category info category. Name Ed fox.
caitlin: category name 110. But you ask questions, expand toolbar.
caitlin: Let's see, I have a dog. So I'm gonna do dog.
caitlin: Oh.
caitlin: budget like a maximum amount of money characters enter 3 50. Make the next. write the mail budget, write the maximum characters, enter 3 50
caitlin: budget break, and that's the amount of money you can spend in this kind of box
caitlin: windows on keyboard, too. 0,
caitlin: 0 8, 5
caitlin: 0.
caitlin: Not sure. Why, talkbys having trouble entering things in today?
caitlin: Or maybe it's me.
caitlin: I think 250 got a box budget. Alright, perfect. Alright your text button
caitlin: your next one.
caitlin: I didn't like that.
caitlin: And this add income button. It'd be helpful. If it said.
caitlin: add category, button, double tap.
caitlin: Keep working
caitlin: money, manager, detective icon, add button annotation, button windows, share audio, get it detected alright. We'll do one more
caitlin: budget category info. Good morning. Anybody you ask corn, Shawn.
caitlin: I'm actually gonna use my external keyboard for this. because dealing with the on screen keyboard is.
caitlin: as you saw, a little creepy turning on external keyword.
caitlin: Okay.
caitlin: perfect. And the handy thing about that is when I type on my external keyboard. I can actually remain my screen. Your focus remains on the edit field itself rather than going in the edit field. And and I have to, you know, actually touch the middle of the screen and find find the edit field so I can continue swiping. So
caitlin: keep more chilling. Expand to warm. Alright, let's do. I don't know
caitlin: me, too.
caitlin: Stop, share one window, zoom 0 8 0
caitlin: 0 0
caitlin: heading. Do you want to get a box budget? Okay? So to the right. Your text button?
caitlin: Right? And that's not amount of money, anything. But keep your hand. I got her.
caitlin: Okay. My next task is to
caitlin: add an income. Okay, I've I've already seen that. So in order to go. But it's more options. But it's under more options still that
caitlin: okay, in this section. It would be really helpful to have these labeled as buttons that are links. Just so I can know that I can confidently, confidently know that I can interact with these
caitlin: as it as it sits currently, they just kind of look like little bits of text. So I hope that I can interact with them. Okay, add income. Know that
caitlin: adding fun. One more question.
caitlin: Okay, money amount, double tap.
caitlin: Keep more tone. 9, 6,
caitlin: 6, 3. That's face free. 6
caitlin: for that 0. Come on not too far. Stop share button, you know. Zoom 0 at 9 0
caitlin: 0 0, 0. Okay, touch heading 3,000 in a box. Let me help me know about your wallet.
caitlin: Windows sound keyboard. That's weird, Andrew. More 0,
caitlin: I think 3,000 bucks. Let me know we know what? You're willing. Okay, we'll do that. Separate your text button.
caitlin: Okay, how do I add? Add, okay, add income. That one is labeled properly. I find it interesting that on this screen the add income button is you have to swipe back to the left, but on the other screen for both, adding expenses and adding categories. The add Button is swipable to the right.
caitlin: That's a little a little confusing double-tap
caitlin: your wallet contains. Now 3,000 editor. Keep working editor. I like that. I read that little alert says your wallet now contains 30,000.
caitlin: That's very useful to know. Okay, what do I do next? Let's see. add some expenses, transactions.
caitlin: category. Name more options, budget categories.
caitlin: Okay, open navigation drawer, one open navigation drawer menu money manager. One expenses
caitlin: once expenses. Double tap. Yeah, one's expenses.
caitlin: It'd be helpful to know that this is a checkable. I think these are radio buttons. but I'm not sure because it's not saying $0, $250. So it would be super helpful to know that that is
caitlin: on on that section. When you're changing to from category to expenses, expenses to category that those are
caitlin: radio buttons, 0% like thought. 0 0% food. Alright.
caitlin: you're expensive. This one food and list 0% slayer. no 0% $0 to one transportation 0% select
caitlin: $0. Do you want? Okay, just looking at the screen? So far, it's got 0, both a slider and $0 spent total expenses, total expenses and and expense perfect total tap.
caitlin: So a new transaction
caitlin: product category, you got it back on down product category and part of category. I can't knock down Mr. Food.
caitlin: This is detected icon list. I don't know if this is labeled or not because it does say food, which is a label that I gave the category that we'd like to add in food. So let's do that
caitlin: enter info. Does that mean? Like
caitlin: the amount? Character center 0 10. Enter info. Get a box, enter info transaction 8.
caitlin: So there's 2 enter info boxes here. I'm not sure what I'm supposed to type in both. One has a character count, so I assume that's letters, and one, I assume, would ring up numbers, but it'd be helpful to have more descriptive labels.
caitlin: Forget about it.
caitlin: I'm gonna grab my external keyword again.
caitlin: Thank you for your patience.
Any for that.
caitlin: Okay, we have a local place called Kruger. So that's just what I typed in for the place, you know, that would typically shop. Yep, okay, so just before that. So I have punctuation turned off
caitlin: But just before that
caitlin: turned off by meaning my screener doesn't read like commas periods. It just uses intonation to let me know those things are there.
caitlin: So if it said dollar sign
caitlin: I, of course, didn't hear it. But interestingly, when I double tapped on that. It did say Dollar sign briefly, I don't know why. I don't know if that's because that was automatically put in the edit field, or if that was the label it was reading. I assume that was input into the edit field. But
caitlin: don't know if I can verify that
no time.
caitlin: Oh. interesting.
caitlin: interesting director 6 of 10 and kind of like ibuprofen.
caitlin: Give me just a second. I'll explain what I'm doing in a moment.
That's all.
caitlin: Okay.
caitlin: no time getting a 25 bucks. No time.
caitlin: The dollar sign is actually after the edit box, which is interesting.
Okay, okay, boss.
caitlin: And it's just labeled, okay, it's just labeled, Enter Info. Okay? It'd be helpful to say, like, I don't know. Money spent.
caitlin: Something more descriptive than inter info
caitlin: to expel confusion. So we will say. I don't know. 150.
caitlin: No time.
caitlin: I think. 150. Okay.
caitlin: alright. Let's separate your text. Button, transaction date.
caitlin: transaction date 2024, 2024. That's fine. January 20, seventh.
caitlin: twenty-seventh. That's fine. 2024,
caitlin: February second, 2024. Let's actually make sure we can change a date. We'll say we spent it on February second, Friday, February second, 2024 selected
caitlin: Yay, it says, selected. That's so helpful.
caitlin: February third, February fourth, Alright selected. February select, February February 9, 2024, February sixteenth, 2020, fourth February fourteenth, February tenth 2024, Ends, up, your text button characters, 6, 10 characters, 6 of 10. Product category.
caitlin: Touch it back, calm down, knock down list, food program, box, enterprise, editing, 150, transaction day, free. February second.
caitlin: February 1520240, I don't actually know how to move along.
caitlin: Okay, I guess we have to suck through the whole calendar. February 1620. Yep.
caitlin: Transition. Okay.
caitlin: So it was a little tedious for the screener to to need to swipe through the entire calendar to get to the add transaction. Button one way could be to have the transaction add transaction button, maybe also at the top, which I realize is, you know, changing things pretty significantly.
caitlin: or maybe once the date has been selected, maybe the calendar should close. I think that might be a little bit easier. I don't know how doable either of those are. But those are my suggestions. Just to go swiping the through the entire calendar.
caitlin: Actually want to try something. Okay, put myself back on the calendar.
caitlin: I'm going to navigate. But with 3 fingers swept down and also
caitlin: okay and navigate it to something called controls. Now, if I press, or if I swipe down, I can navigate navigate to the next control, which should be that button. So let's try. February 1620, 24.
caitlin: So February seventeenth, 2024.
caitlin: Oh, okay, those are also seen as controls. Okay? Oh, one thing I wanted to mention. These aren't labeled as buttons or links. So it'd be helpful, or check boxes, or whatever they might be. It would be helpful to know which element this is.
caitlin: So. Okay, I gotta talk through the whole thing.
caitlin: February 26. Today. February 20, eighth February 2920 transaction button. Okay, add transaction. Button.
caitlin: Second, option concession, but 53 equals one production equals program
caitlin: 1 6 open navigation door, but expenses more options, fun category. Name your expenses this month 30. So according to this, I've spent 30 in my
caitlin: food category, $500, $150 out of 500 $0. Annotation. That expense. One window. My manager. Okay. Add expense.
caitlin: happy transaction! I come down, enter, forget it. I come down rocket.
caitlin: pop, window, moving list.
caitlin: Say, we spend something for the dog, that new transaction
caitlin: enter and forget a box detected by calm down. Write down, let's go out. Enter and forget anybody. You ask Cori Shawn on that life my phone down so I can type.
caitlin: I think having dog food next to food might be a little confusing. But since already okay, I go name dog and food.
caitlin: I always call her
caitlin: meal, no matter what time it is dinner. So we will put dinner.
caitlin: your text button.
caitlin: and we will say 100,
caitlin: editing, 100 bucks entrance. Oh, okay.
caitlin: dollar sign clear text, but transaction date 2,024 to February 27 previous month, button next month, button, February the first 2,024 next month, button previous month, Button.
February, February, February fourth, 24,
caitlin: February, February sixth, February seventh, 2025, February 20 February ninth, 25, February tenth, Saturday, February tenth, 20. Fourth.
caitlin: better
caitlin: February 29. Transaction transaction
caitlin: connection. But if you're equals 2 but nothing equals there.
caitlin: I assume it's not supposed to read that. It says like product, and some jumbled up letters and product
caitlin: or something equals. I assume it's just supposed to say like. I don't know the expense added, or something like that, that'd be a little more useful.
caitlin: I don't even know if I screen you're supposed to read that part. Total expenses.
caitlin: $0, 200 fine. Interesting. That total expenses doesn't have anything next to it. Yet 0 transportation. Okay.
caitlin: pop up window, not transportation transportation, add new transaction.
caitlin: enter in, forget it, characters enter, forget it. English, us cordial
like the one.
caitlin: Okay, we will say we're
caitlin: editing or edit box. Clear text. Button characters enter 4, 10,
caitlin: enter and find a box. No time
any more. Tell
caitlin: spend $30
caitlin: editing 40 edit. Box. Enter
caitlin: dollar, sign your text, button, concession 8, 2024 to February 20, seventh.
caitlin: alright. June, February 20, seventh select. On that day.
caitlin: radius month, button next month, button, February first 2024, February second, 2024,
caitlin: Friday, February second, 2024,
caitlin: February twentieth, 20, February, February, February, February, February twelfth, February February 29,
caitlin: second Gotcha. Concession, but 53 equals 3 production equals, 0 price equals 31, 0 white equals 3, 5, 3, 2, 9, 1 0.
caitlin: Okay, yeah, just read, basically, product name. I don't know why. It's just product. But you know Uber or the category, and then uber and
caitlin: the price and the date. Okay, I've added some spinces. What do we do next?
caitlin: Check in total, how much you have spent? Okay, screen button annotation, fun windows, share audio.
caitlin: good transportation, 15% slider.
caitlin: $3, $200,
caitlin: total expenses unless total expenses. It doesn't actually say anything. Do I have to double tap?
caitlin: Okay, I double tap 3 times. Nothing happened. My screener is not able to read how many of what the total expenses are.
caitlin: Okay. Edit one edit. One of your budget categories to change the name and save it.
caitlin: $30. 15. Transportation, 100 dog, 100 double tap.
caitlin: Nope can't do that. 100 drinks. How do we do that
caitlin: category interesting. This is category name. I don't know. If that means, do I double that there
caitlin: your census category name
more options, fun once expenses.
caitlin: open navigation, draw open our vacation drawers, check
caitlin: budget list, 500 200 tab here.
caitlin: Budget category info, yeah. Characters. Enter 3 50. Okay, dog edit box category. Name, change the category. Name together
caitlin: much you ask. Rachel
caitlin: says you cannot change the name money manager. I don't know what that means.
caitlin: but then it says editing. So we'll try, anyway.
caitlin: Okay?
caitlin: Oh, it inserted me before
caitlin: or in.
caitlin: Alright I navigated with 3 fingers, swipe down until I hear the word word, and then I swipe down with a single finger to get behind the word dog.
caitlin: That's me that's on me.
caitlin: not on the app at all. Okay, characters 250 clear text button amount of money you can spend
caitlin: can't get into the add income. It's so confusing.
caitlin: I didn't come. Money, manager, food and list. Alright. Let's swipe 500 dog stuff, 250 dog stuff. Okay, that worked alright. What am I supposed to do next
caitlin: after order to create a budget plan
caitlin: and add a deadline for any day next month. Oh, boy, I don't know how to do that.
caitlin: Well, let's find out
caitlin: 500 food budget. Okay, can I double that on that
caitlin: category name, more options, fun
caitlin: budget categories, check buddy categories, budget analysis. analysis. The expenses, body plans. budget plans. Okay? I think that's it.
caitlin: Okay? Yeah. Annotation. One windows budget plans. Window manager
caitlin: check what it plans.
caitlin: Okay? Navigation. Buddy. Plans. Okay.
caitlin: deline for any day. Next month's fun. Alright! Your wallet contains enough money for this plan. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan. The deadline of this plan has passed. The deadline of this plan has passed.
caitlin: It's a little confusing, so it says, your wallet contains enough money for this. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan, and that's up to the right. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan. Your wallet contains enough money for this plan. Swip right. The deadline of this plan has passed. The deadline of this plan has passed. Swipe right. The deadline of this plan has passed. The deadline of this plan has passed. I don't know why it reads it twice.
caitlin: and I don't know if these are buttons links, just bits of text. I'm not sure what this is. I kind of button. Okay? Detected icon. Add button again. This is another unlabel button. So if that could be labeled as add, that'd be super helpful double tap
caitlin: plan info plan. I open a box
caitlin: plan, title. I don't know. I would call that
caitlin: Hmm! We'll say march.
caitlin: boxline title, perfect separate
caitlin: characters. Enter 5 to 50, plan, description, edit, box, plan, description.
caitlin: I don't know. Characters enter 0 50
caitlin: characters entered land description in a box. Characters entered 0 50 lans budget edit box plans. Budget dollar, sign keeper telling.
caitlin: Oh. we'll say 800
caitlin: getting the 100 bucks. My budget.
caitlin: Your text button planned deadline date plan, deadline date 2024,
caitlin: June, February 20, seventh. Bring this month, button next month, button next month, button
caitlin: previous month to February 20 seventh.
caitlin: 1B s. What? What? What? What? What? What?
March 1320, 24,
caitlin: march march fifteenth, 2020, march fifteenth, Friday, March fifteenth, 2020.
caitlin: Geranyo annotation fun.
caitlin: There we go. Okay, again. It'd be helpful to have that add add plan, button.
caitlin: either at the top of the screen, so I could just easily not have to easily get up there and tap it, or and not have to slip through the category or
caitlin: calendar either call sounding word, and and or once a date has been selected. If the calendar itself would collapse, that would be super super helpful. That will have.
caitlin: You're planning successfully. Money manager money manager
caitlin: detected like on that button.
caitlin: Okay, I've done that. Lastly, check out the 2 analysis results.
caitlin: Okay. I wonder if that's on the screen? Your wallet contains enough money, more options, fun
caitlin: your wallet, your wallet contains enough money for this plan. Okay, your wallet contains enough money for this plan. It's still repeated twice the deadline. If this plan has passed and this plan has passed. That is not true, because it lies next month.
caitlin: The deadline of this plan has passed again. That repeat repeats twice, march from March fifteenth. $2,400 a list.
caitlin: I'm not sure what the instruction mean by lastly, check out the 2 analysis results. So let's look on the dropdown. I mean the menu. Just a little bit plans
caitlin: real quick
caitlin: annotation by now. So deadline your wallet. More options, budget plans.
caitlin: Okay. Navigation for one double-tap. Oh, that's okay.
caitlin: Alright. That was a little unclear in the in the instructions. I wasn't sure what it meant. Analysis. Okay, budget analysis and monthly expenses, analogy, analysis. Look at budget budget analysis, double tap.
caitlin: What analysis?
caitlin: Interesting that that didn't say checked every time I tapped on something from this little screen, it says checked.
caitlin: So I wonder if that's just like a butter link? It would be really, really helpful to have that information separate's fun. have you? What view I try and find your expenses for category. This one, with 3 points
caitlin: and value is 30 maps. Value is 150 particle.
caitlin: It's cool pie chart and then describes it.
caitlin: Travel version, transportation, transportation, food, transportation, transportation.
caitlin: They are annotation on windows. Zoom is an R.
caitlin: Yeah. This this is not particularly accessible to a screen, reader, I thought it was going to be, but I don't know what it means.
caitlin: So pie chart makes sense pie chart entitled. And then it kind of describes it. There has the minimum
caitlin: minimum expenses for category this month with 3 points.
caitlin: Yeah, value is 30. Max value is 150. That's perfect. It tells me that it has 3 data points that's really good to know. But then the confusion starts with, what does this all mean trial version. I assume that's just something that they're using that money managers using to maybe like, make the chart. That's okay. Transportation dog stuff, food, food.
kind of makes sense.
caitlin: I try and title your text. Oops. Sorry.
caitlin: That's a little confusing. Alright. Let's go to the other analysis. Open navigation drawer. Double tap. Can you let me manager? And again, just to get to that, I just touch on the screen where I thought it would be, and then
caitlin: move from there. Check budget analysis on the expense analysis. Oh, it's actually checked weird. Usually, it says, checked. But it didn't say check this time after I double tapped it checked on the expense. Okay? Monthly expenses. Analysis, still without
caitlin: check, this time. Interesting. Didn't say last time.
caitlin: I really appreciate that when I double tap on the little check, I assume is a radio button. I want to check box check.
caitlin: I assume that when I check it
caitlin: not assume I'm so sorry my words are tangled with this morning. Let's try that again.
caitlin: I really appreciate that when you check one of the Rio buttons in on that particular screen that it automatically takes you to the new. I don't know. Section new screen and you don't have to like, navigate your way out of that menu. That's just an extra added step that would be
caitlin: not helpful. So I really appreciate that it automatically. Once you check something, it automatically takes you to the new screen
caitlin: window manager. More options, one says by view, which is just something random that dropbox says, I guess, to let you know that there's web content. I'm not sure that's nothing to do with the app. I see that all over the place, and there it doesn't, is not able to read anything on this page. Unfortunately.
caitlin: Is there anything else in the instructions?
caitlin: Okay, so I've completely tasked to the best of my ability. I guess else.
caitlin: Unfortunately, this was
caitlin: sorry. Talk back is chattering.
caitlin: Unfortunately, there's some things that need to be worked on. There's a couple only buttons.
caitlin: There are a bunch of screens with elements that aren't identified as their particular element type, such as buttons, potentially links, radio buttons.
caitlin: There is an edit field on the
caitlin: when you're adding an expense
caitlin: that is just
caitlin: labeled in info, or something like that, and and don't know the particular label off top my head, but it'd be helpful if it was labeled I don't know. Add
caitlin: money, expense, or something like that just something more helpful than info button.
caitlin:  the when you're making a category, the add category button isn't slippled, as I think it says. Add expense, or add income or something like that.
caitlin: Those are the major things I can think of. Off the top of my head
caitlin: that you'd need a little bit of work on in order for it to be fully usable by screen reader users.
caitlin: Oh, and the the radio buttons.
caitlin: I think I mentioned that couple times. I assume they're radio buttons
caitlin: trying to think if there's anything else.
caitlin: I don't think so. So I think if those things were improved that this would be really, really oh, sorry.
caitlin: The the chart
caitlin: both of the analysis screens are confusing
caitlin: the
caitlin: monthly expenses. I think it is like I don't know. I don't know. It doesn't say the screen I'm currently on is completely inaccessible.
caitlin: and the other one with the pie chart was sort of accessible, but it was confusing, because it said, one of the categories. I can't remember what it was. I think it was transportation. It said 0 to 0, which doesn't make any sense to me.
caitlin:  yes, so I think if these things were fixed, it would it would be
caitlin: close to
caitlin: fully accessible. Of course I can't speak for the other sections that I haven't explored, but I think if these things were were fixed it would be go a long way to making it
caitlin: an accessible app for the blind. So
caitlin: thank you very much for your continued commitment to accessibility. Thank you for allowing me to find my thoughts and be back. And thanks, Wilson.